we've only had a couple days together  but how do you feel about me edward  eddie  ed  [Music]  here in espanol  i feel love  but you know when you and me talk about  our relationship i feel  tiene muchas expectativas  have high high expectations and  people ask a lot and  don't allow things to be  people ask a lot and do not allow things  to be  well  the few days that i've spent with you i  feel a connection  i like you  go brenden  is  okay  well  can i say something  let's see  i'm trying to understand  i really am but it's really confusing  so i'm thinking to myself i'm in you i  like you i think you're into me you know  let's see where this can go i  want to take you  to men's and neil to see the la playa  um and carlo if he wants to come to  mejordi  yo te  oh my god i think i understood that  yeah you're from manzanillo of course  um can i drive can i drive maybe maybe  [Music]